I talked to Robert Downey jr. about this
who by the way I saw him Saturday night
I said Oh Paul Rudd's coming on the show
was he like he goes he's been nicest guy
ever man yeah and I know you hate that I
don't hate it you you don't want to be
known as the nice guy but he literally
said to me quote he is the nicest he's
great that's another guy that I'm a
little awed by and I said to him Tony
Stark you had a real liking but you know
you say I remember I read Iron Man
comics my entire life and Tony Stark was
this character but if I had to actually
make him come to life it would be a very
difficult task for me to envision all
that yeah so when you get something like
ant-man you took ant-man and made
something [ __ ] great out of it oh
thanks but the point is you have to sit
down like with any acting won't say who
the [ __ ] is ant-man I what is the
process I don't know I if you look at a
guy like Robert Downey jr. when he is
doing Iron Man I feel like there's such
a looseness with him yeah and the way he
kind of interprets things away he
interacts with people but certainly he
takes on this role and there's a freedom
to just kind of make it whatever he
wants to make it but he made a decision
but he and so you it's he then created
something where you can't even imagine
another actor in that part see that's
why would this Scorsese thing saying Oh
Marvel movies aren't cinema and Robert
you know was was had weighed in on that
made news because he said well they're
in movie theaters I know that right are
you insulted by that - when Scorsese
says it's not cinema I mean I'm not
insult I'm not insulted by anybody
saying anything really I don't get too
bad you know and I you know I think but
is it cinema it is I think it is it is
and isn't coming up with the ant-man
character just as difficult as being in
any movie ever did well ultimately you
really care about relationships with
people I mean it isn't it isn't all just
special effects driven it and action
whatever genre it falls into you know
you want to see people in human behavior
and talking to each other and I know
that well we're working on these things
we care about the characters right and
we you know we I am Adam I have a whole
relationship with my daughter right now
where and that you know the human
struggles of being a Sioux
for hero and there's so I think we're
we're trying to deal with human issues
and things that are relatable that I got
just rides I think because they were
comic books somehow people think these
roles are frivolous and it doesn't
matter what you're doing wells matter
you gotta make me believe that ant-man
is a real [ __ ] guy I also think that
you know movies it's all just changed so
much that there used to be and this is
just a the way that it all functions now
with studios and they're not making
middle you know budgeted films for as
much and that's why so many those
writers and I'm going to television